foreign
for CBS deals and this morning some of
the most popular items we've showcased
from items for the home cook to those on
the Go and all at exclusive low prices
to start shopping now scan the QR code
on your screen or simply visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with more good morning
good morning okay this is exciting
everything here is going to give you a
little bit more power power keywords
starting with jump smart this is the
only device that I will ever use to jump
start my car because it is foolproof it
is also a 10 in one device you could use
it as a flashlight as a charger as a
thermometer a compass you name it it has
it jump start your car your truck your
boat your lawnmower when you say
foolproof you mean it won't shock you
exactly any trouble so for 119.99 25 off
today you can have the power to restart
your car all you do is Hook the red to
the red black to the black and if it
doesn't if for somehow you don't do that
correctly it just beeps it's not going
to shock you so you can do it okay for
our home cook the power to cook quickly
and healthy okay this is called the
crisper lid you just put it on any 10 to
12 inch pan the deeper the better and
then it turns any pan into what like a
convection oven or an air fryer will do
so it swirls the air around really fast
and it's going to give you crispy
healthier quicker cooked food it also
comes with that nice shelf to elevate
the food make it happen a little bit
more quickly this is a no-brainer
because the air fryer takes up so much
space it does in the kitchen and this is
only 32.99 45 off today a secret I
already got that for breakfast I'm just
gonna love it yes okay more power the
power to charge multiple devices at the
same time so this you put plug this into
the wall it's charging while it's
plugged in you can plug in multiple
devices into this and it also is a
device that you can just put your phone
on top and it will charge and then
there's a digital display on the top
this is only 49.99 today it is 38 off
this is something you will get so much
use out of
it's incredible you said
49.99 yes 49.99 I have to say that these
usually are way higher exactly and super
Sleek come in multiple colors I feel
like I want one of these in every room
in my house alrighty and then it's a
portable charger too now we don't see a
lot of these anymore so this is
something that I just for peace of mind
the react seven in one this is only
27.99 it's 44 off and this is just to
have in an emergency situation it has a
seat belt cutter it has a flashlight it
has a window breaker that will break the
glass if heaven forbid you have to use
that there is an emergency alert SOS
there you go honestly it's small enough
you could stick this in your purse if
you feel threatened set that off you
know flashlight charger everything you
could need and this is so small and Chic
and again 20 less than thirty dollars
27.99 power and safe power safety a
little bit of air fried food everything
we need how about that Ashley Bellman
thank you and of course we partner with
all of these companies to get these
deals to buy anything you saw today
simply scan that QR code on your screen
or head on over to cbsdeals.com